damit kommen wir zum nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt die auf die Fraktion
möchte einen Untersuchungsausschuss
einsetzen es wäre der zweite
Untersuchungsausschuss dieser 20
Wahlperiode in dem sie die Maßnahmen der
Bundesregierung zur Eindämmung des
Corona-Virus noch einmal analysieren
möchte sie möchte hinterfragen inwieweit
diese Eingriffe in die Freiheit der
bürgerverhältnismäßig waren und ob diese
Maßnahmen überhaupt geholfen haben die
Verbreitung des Virus ein zu dämmen nach
Vorschlag der afd-fraktion soll dass
dieser Untersuchungsausschuss aus 16
Abgeordneten bestehen und im Idealfall
sollen auf Grundlage der gewonnenen
Erkenntnisse dann auch
Handlungsempfehlungen für den Fall einer
zukünftig auftretenden Pandemie
erarbeitet werden können für die
afd-fraktion wird nun Thomas Seitz der
rechtspolitische Sprecher der Fraktion
diesen Antrag vorstellen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren wir sind jetzt
unseren Bürgern schuldig alle Maßnahmen
staatlicher Stellen im Zusammenhang mit
Corona kritisch aufzuarbeiten um das
herzustellen was die Regierung seit 2020
verweigert Transparenz und
Nachvollziehbarkeit
über 70 kleinen Anfragen unserer
Fraktion zu Corona blieben meist ohne
echte antworten weil alte wie neue
Regierung darin versagt haben in
ausreichenden Umfang valide Daten
hinsichtlich Effektivität Effizienz und
Risiken ihrer Maßnahmen zu erheben
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach nutzt
wissenschaftliche Evidenz nur wenn es
Ihnen beliebt und ihn bestätigt wenn
nicht ignoriert er sie oder weshalb
sonst hält der Minister an Maßnahmen
fest deren Bilanz laut
Expertenkommission vernichtend ist und
wo Zahlen Daten Fakten vorliegen sind
diese auf politisch kontaminiert ich
nenne als Beispiel die Fallzahlen die
mit der Anzahl anlassloser Tests ohne
medizinische aussagekräft politisch
gesteuert wurden oder denken wir an die
Zahl der verfügbaren Krankenhausbetten
die nicht wegen der Belegung mit kranken
gesunken ist sondern mittels Krankenhaus
Refinanzierung und personenschlüssel
gewollt verknappt wurde nicht genug mit
der Einführung der einrichtungsbezogenen
Impfpflicht haben sie den
Personalnotstand im Gesundheitsbereich
noch verschärft und tausende von
Menschen aus ihrem Beruf gedrängt
oder denken wir an die Manipulation bei
der Bewertung der Impfwirkung wenn bei
geimpften nur symptomatische Fälle
gezählt wurden bei den umgeimpften
jedoch jeder positive zwangstest
jeder Tote ist ein toter zu viel wie oft
wurde das hier im Haus ausgesprochen es
war das Totschlagargument schlechthin
seit einiger Zeit sterben trotz
nachlassender im Wirkung nur noch wenige
Menschen an Corona in den Altersgruppen
65 bis 74 und das ist besonders fatal in
der Altersgruppe 15 bis 44 haben wir
seit impfbeginn aber eine stetig
wachsende unerklärliche
Übersterblichkeit aber eben nicht an
Corona wo ist der Wille dies aufzuklären
neben den massiven wirtschaftlichen und
finanziellen Folgen der Maßnahmen sind
vor allem die gravierenden Auswirkungen
auf die allgemeine Gesundheit bis heute
unausgewertet bei Erwachsenen geht es um
die Frage und die Folgen verschleppter
Behandlungen und Operationen um Angst
und Zwangsstörungen Depressionen und
sucht Erkrankungen Kinder und
Jugendliche brauchen für eine gesunde
Entwicklung in ganz besonderem Maße
Sozialkontakte weshalb sie die größten
Opfer der maßnahmenpolitik waren die
Zunahme von Essstörungen Depressionen
und Angstattacken ist erschreckend die
Zahl der Suizidversuche im zweiten
corona-lockdown hat sich bei Kindern
verdreifacht das ist das Ergebnis ihrer
Politik
und was schreibt Herr Lauterbach in
seinem aktuellen quengelbrief an die
über 60-Jährigen Zitat mir ist bewusst
dass viele das Thema Corona nicht mehr
hören mögen doch leider ist die
corona-pandemie noch nicht vorbei Zitat
Ende doch Herr Lauterbach sie ist vorbei
fast alle Länder haben die Pandemie für
beendet erklärt und es wird akzeptiert
dass das Virus längst indem ich ist die
Menschen haben ihre Willkür
satellauterbach ihre ewigen
untergangspredigten Drohungen
Ermahnungen und Bevormundungen es kann
keiner mehr hören wer eine Maske tragen
will soll dies tun aber die meisten
Menschen tragen den Maulkorb nicht um
einer totbringenden Seuche zu entgehen
sondern rein aus Angst vor Strafe die
Mehrzahl der Menschen hat sich auch
nicht aus medizinischer Überzeugung
impfen lassen sondern um sozialem Druck
zu entgehen für Arbeit oder Studium für
Sport oder Urlaub eine Schande und
fehlende Kenntnis der Mittel- und
langfristigen Nebenfolgen der Impfungen
kommen oben drauf
das Volk hat ein Recht auf Antwort was
genau gelaufen ist und das Parlament hat
die verdammte pflichtauskunft zu geben
es geht aber um mehr als um Aufklärung
von Versäumnissen und
Verantwortlichkeiten um mehr als
Aufarbeitung der Fehlentscheidung und
ihrer gravierenden Auswirkungen wir
brauchen die Ergebnisse des
Untersuchungsausschusses als Grundlage
für eine umfassende rechtspolitische
Diskussion um zukünftig das Grundgesetz
um eine zivile Notstandsverfassung zu
ergänzen freihändige völlig
unverhältnismäßige Grundrechtseingriffe
dürfen sich nicht wiederholen nie wieder
der Gesetzgeber ist hier dringend
gefordert um eine weitere Erosion des
Rechtsstaats zu verhindern und für die
Lauterbach dieser Welt rote Linien zu
ziehen meine Damen und Herren natürlich
ist mir bewusst dass sie den Antrag
ablehnen werden nicht nur weil sie
Aufklärung scheuen sondern einfach
deshalb weil er von der AFD kommt ich
sage Ihnen nur zu denn irgendwann wird
dem Bürger die Begründung die böse AFD
nicht mehr ausreichen sie werden dann
noch mehr Rückhalt und Glaubwürdigkeit
in der Bevölkerung verlieren oder sie
trauen sich und Stimmen für die
Transparenz ihrer Politik durch ein
Untersuchungsausschuss vielen Dank
Thomas Seitz hat hier begründet warum
die afd-fraktion einen
Untersuchungsausschuss möchte
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen mit diesem
chaotischen Antrag der uns vorliegt und
vor allem auch der eben gehörten Rede
der AFD wird noch einmal unterstrichen
wie verantwortungslos sie auch in den
letzten zwei Jahren hier an diesem Pult
geredet und auch gehandelt haben oder
ich erinnere mich
an die vielen haltlosen Beiträge ihrer
scheinexperten aus den Anhörungen was
sie sich hier seit Beginn der Pandemie
geleistet haben ist nichts anderes als
Desinformationen durch Fake Daten
Einschüchterung und Destruktion statt
konstruktiver Kritik die systematische
Beschädigung von Expertinnen und
Experten und maßgeblichen Institutionen
dieses Staates sie meinen es nicht gut
mit unserem Land
nein wer ist ernst nimmt mit der Sorge
um die Menschen in diesem Land der
kümmert sich um ihr Wohlergehen und das
tun wir als SPD seit Beginn der Pandemie
haben wir verlässlich dafür gearbeitet
Schaden von den Menschen abzuwenden und
Leid zu verringern es gab keine
Blaupause für ein solches
pandemie-szenario deshalb gibt es Licht
und Schatten darum gab es in der
pandemiebekämpfung auch
Fehlentscheidungen ja aber es zeichnet
unsere Demokratie aus dass wir
selbstkritisch mit unserem Handeln
umgehen die corona-maßnahmen werden seit
zwei Jahren intensiv und kritisch
debattiert wie kein anderes Thema und wo
immer möglich wurden und werden
notwendige Korrekturen vorgenommen
dieses Vorgehen haben wir mit unserem
Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach
explizit verstärkt unsere Regierung
steht für konsequente Anbindung an
Fachwissen lässt sich beraten durch
einen expertinnenrat aber gerade
Wissenschaft lebt vom Widerstreit
verschiedener Meinungen
Forschung strebt immer nach
Erkenntnisgewinn es gibt nicht die
einfache Lösung und bei allen die die
einzig richtige Lösung verkaufen wollen
da sage ich Vorsicht gerade als
Parlament haben wir unsere Verantwortung
sehr ernst genommen warum können sie
eigentlich nicht mal den Mund halten nee
weil sie den uns weil sie das was ich
hier richtiges sage nicht ertragen
können das ist ihre normal
gerade als Parlament haben wir unsere
Verantwortung sehr ernst genommen die
Breite wissenschaftliche Expertise und
auch internationale Erfahrungen
einzubeziehen verschiedene Perspektiven
auszubalancieren damit die Belastungen
niemanden überfordern und das korrigiert
wird was gravierende Nebenwirkungen hat
und dann nenne ich besonders auch die
Auswirkungen auf die Kinder und
Jugendlichen das tun wir ernsthaft und
fortlaufend unsere Entscheidungen zu
korrigieren
und hier
hier in diesem hier in diesem Haus
sitzen fünf Fraktionen denen es genauso
ernst ist mit einer verantwortungsvollen
pandemie-politik Grüne und FDP haben
auch als Opposition in der vergangenen
Legislaturperiode in weiten Teilen die
Regierungspolitik kritisch und
konstruktiv begleitet so wie die Linken
die es auch heute noch tun ich will nur
mal erinnern an den Antrag zum
corona-schutzgesetz und dadurch sind wir
hier in Deutschland insgesamt durchaus
erfolgreich durch diese schwierigen
Zeiten gekommen was sie aber wollen ist
Zweifel drehen spalten sie nutzten die
Unzufriedenheit der Menschen um sie
aufzubringen gegen den Staat und wenn es
den Menschen schlecht geht dann ist das
gut für die AFD das ist auch ihre Maxime
oder was sie mit ihrem Antrag
was sie mit ihrem Antrag auf Einrichtung
eines
Untersuchungsausschusses hier machen ist
davon ablenken dass sie der eigentliche
Untersuchungsgegenstand sind wenn es um
politisches Versagen in der Pandemie
geht
sie haben wieder besseres Wissen alle
Schutzmaßnahmen abgelehnt sie haben die
Gefährlichkeit des Virus zu keiner Phase
der Pandemie ernst genommen sondern
heruntergespielt und geleugnet und sie
haben durch ihre Falschinformationen
dazu beigetragen dass viele Menschen die
schutzangebote nicht nutzen mit ihrem
Kampf gegen das Impfen gegen das Tragen
von Masken tragen Sie die Verantwortung
für sehr viele Menschen leben deren
vorzeitige sterben hätte verhindert
werden können
Frau Kollegin
natürlich muss es eine lebhafte Debatte
geben können aber Debatte besteht nicht
nur aus Senden ihrem Redner haben vorhin
alle zugehört und vielleicht können Sie
ein bisschen sich mäßigen dass die
Rednerin zumindest ungestört auch ihre
Rede vortragen kann vielen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin dann
wiederhole ich gerne meinen letzten Satz
noch mal mit ihrem Kampf gegen das
Impfen gegen das Tragen von Masken
tragen Sie die Verantwortung für sehr
viele Menschenleben deren vorzeitiges
Leben hätte verhindert werden können
dafür können wir hier keinen
Untersuchungsausschuss einsetzen aber
ich bin froh dass ich um die
Machenschaften ihrer Partei die uns und
sozialen und demokratischen Rechtsstaat
beschädigen jetzt der Verfassungsschutz
gemacht vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
nächster Redner in dieser Debatte ist
Erich irlstorfer für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
Erich Elster versetzt im
Gesundheitsausschuss
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren
der
afd-antrag ist ein für mich zumindest
eine Sammlung an politischen Ideen und
Forderungen die die AFD in den letzten
beiden Jahren zusammengetragen hat
und ich möchte als erstes schon hier in
aller Deutlichkeit feststellen dass so
eine Debatte durchaus möglich sein muss
und dass die Demokratie von solchen
Debatten natürlich auch lebt dass man
hier etwas hat was gefordert wird und
dass man hier natürlich auch
jederzeit das parlamentarische Recht hat
so etwas abzulegen
und
und ich glaube auch dass es notwendig
ist dass man hier in der Wortwahl um den
Umgang und der Parlamentariern natürlich
schon eine gewisse Vorbildfunktion
vielleicht auch bei diesem Thema hat wo
man sagt ja wir gehen wir den
miteinander um und ich glaube wir
sollten hier getrieben sein von einer
hohen Fachlichkeit aber auch von einer
Analyse die ist für die Menschen möglich
macht das komplett auch im Detail zu
verstehen
es hat natürlich wenn man auch die
Reaktionen hier von ihrer Seite hört
dass hier viele Emotionen dabei ist und
das ist generell ja nicht verkehrt weil
es schon mit auch ein Ausdruck von
Leidenschaft ist dass man hinter diesem
Punkten die man hier fordert auch steht
aber es hat natürlich oft auch bei ihren
Aussagen und ich möchte Ihnen das nicht
unterstellen dass sie hier im Volk
Missgunst und Spaltung und dergleichen
senden wollen oder auch streuen wollen
aber es hat den Anschein dass natürlich
schon bewusst auch diese Dinge so
platziert und formuliert werden dass man
das auch annehmen könnte und das ist
etwas was er in meinen Augen schwierig
ist
und
um meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
ich glaube auch diese Forderung nach
einem Untersuchungsausschuss hat
natürlich schon auch einen gewissen
Unterton der hier etwas Negatives über
dieses ganze Thema legt
und ich sagte schon verbale Abrüstung
ist hier ein Instrument dass man nicht
unterschätzen sollte ich möchte aber
schon auch sagen dass es Gründe gibt und
sie haben ja doch gerade reingerufen ja
schon wieder so ein Maskenträger ich
kann Ihnen nur sagen als persönlicher
Betroffenheit wenn man diese Erkrankung
hatte das hat Millionen von Menschen wo
man heute noch Spätfolgen hat darunter
auch leidet darunter natürlich auch eine
Emotion entwickelt hat weil man in
seinem Familien Umfeld den Tod einfach
zu betrauen hatte dann sieht man jetzt
vielleicht anders wie wenn man hier mit
einer leichten Grippe oder was auch
immer davon gekommen ist und hier
wünsche ich mir von ihnen eine gewisse
Sensibilität dass sie hier natürlich das
es ist klar dass sie ihren politischen
Stil haben dass sie das auch machen
wollen aber ich bitte hier einfach um
den nötigen Respekt auch und ich möchte
noch mal betonen zumindest für die Zeit
der großen Koalition dass wir im
Gesundheitsausschuss und auch jetzt
unter der ampelregierung die
Fachlichkeit und das Miteinander an
erste Stelle immer gestellt haben und
dass man hier auch abgewogen hat
Maßnahmen zu ergreifen die politisch
natürlich nicht schön sind ich kann das
selbst aus persönlichen Erfahrungen im
Wahlkampf natürlich auch wie so viele
andere berichten wo es Gastronomen gab
die mich nicht mal mehr in Ihre Räume
gelassen haben weil sie gesagt haben ihr
wart dabei dass wir hier gastronomische
Einrichtungen zugesperrt haben all diese
Dinge sind ja wirklich in der Realität
aber wir waren geleitet
in der vorherigen Regierung und jetzt
auch was wir leiden von den Menschen
nehmen wollten das wird Tod verhindern
wollten und dass wir nach
wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnissen die
Menschen schützen wollten und der Spagat
der Wirtschaftlichkeit waren es
natürlich wichtig dass wir hier nicht
Unternehmungen und Unternehmen gängeln
oder natürlich vernichten dass man
niemals das Ziel und das möchte ich
schon in aller Deutlichkeit die auch
einmal sagen
Minister sparen und auch Minister
lauterbach
haben in einer Art und Weise hier immer
auch gewarnt jeder hat natürlich seinen
eigenen Stil und natürlich kommen jetzt
wo wir zwei Jahre weiter sind sagen ja
vollkommen falsch aber die Propheten die
es mir nachher erklären die sind mir
immer die allerliebsten wir brauchen
vorher natürlich hier die Richtungen
wenn man Entscheidungen treffen muss das
ist doch das entscheidende und wenn hier
Minister Lauterbach sagt dass die
Pandemie das hat er heute wieder gesagt
nicht zu Ende ist dann kann ich nur
sagen da hat er Recht und
und ich kann Ihnen nur auch immer wieder
sagen dass ziel muss es sein die
Menschen in einer Krise mitzunehmen den
Menschen verständlich zu kommunizieren
was Sache ist natürlich auf der
Grundlage von Wissenschaftlern Forschung
und das muss auch klar sein dass man ins
gelingen verliebt ist ich sage das immer
wieder und da muss man zusammenarbeiten
und da ist es egal ob in Regierung oder
in Opposition und das ist die Bitte
natürlich auch an sie kommen Sie hier in
das Boot der Demokraten zurück die sich
bemühen für die Menschen da zu sein
nicht nur mit Worten und mit Sätzen
sondern setzen Sie auf Zusammenarbeit
setzen sie auf Lösung wir müssen diese
Situation meistern das ist das Ziel was
die Menschen haben und das ist auch der
Auftrag an die Politik herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
Erich elstorfer war das hier mit
seiner Erwiderung auf das begehrene
afd-fraktion einen
Untersuchungsausschuss einzusetzen für
die Grünen spricht nun ihre
parlamentarische Geschäftsführerin der
Fraktion Irene Michalitsch meine liebe
Kollegen seit dem Einzug der AFD in den
Deutschen Bundestag haben wir leider
immer wieder das gleiche Bild immer
wieder werden parlamentarische
Initiativen eingebracht die selbst
kleinsten Standards nicht genügen und
dazu noch auf stumpfe Weise ihre
hasserfüllten Ideen und ihr reaktionäres
Weltbild produzieren meine Damen und
Herren es geht ihnen entweder darum
marginalisierte Gruppen zu diffamieren
oder um Stimmungsmache meistens um
beides nun hat die AFD einen Antrag zur
Einsetzung eines
Untersuchungsausschusses zum Thema
corona-pandemie vorgelegt sie geben vor
sie geben vor das Verhalten der
Bundesregierung im Zusammenhang mit der
pandemiebekämpfung aufarbeiten zu wollen
aber dabei geht es ihnen eigentlich vor
allem um Stimmungsmache in ihren Blasen
denn seien Sie doch mal ehrlich welche
Ziele verfolgen sie denn seit Beginn der
Pandemie die Kollegin Behrens der
Kollege irrsdorfer haben es eben finde
ich eindrucksvoll geschildert ihrer
Fraktion ist nicht am Wohle des von
ihnen vermeintlich so geliebten Volkes
gelegen ihnen geht es um Hass und
Spaltung
und damit ist nicht zu sagen damit ist
nicht zu sagen dass jede Maßnahme der
Vorgängerregierung zielführend und
sinnvoll war wir haben uns auch immer
wieder mit Kritik in diese Debatten
eingebracht aber haben am Ende in einem
großen demokratischen Konsens eben im
Sinne des Gelingens die Maßnahmen auch
mitgetragen und wir haben natürlich auch
stärkere Anstrengungen angemahnt und
sehen Sie es mir nach die Kollegen und
Kollegen von der Union auch maskendeals
im Grund im Kunstkreis ihrer Partei
bieten natürlich Anlass zur Aufarbeitung
aber insgesamt aber insgesamt war es
eine Kraftanstrengung der
verantwortungsbewussten Bürgerinnen und
Bürger und der demokratischen Fraktionen
hier im Haus die Pandemie und diese
vorher nie dagewesene Situation
bestmöglich zu meistern meine Damen und
Herren und ihr aufklärungswille und ihr
aufklärungswille bei der AFD ja davon
konnten wir uns in der letzten
Wahlperiode eindrücklich ein Bild machen
ich kann mich noch sehr gut an den
Untersuchungsausschuss zum Anschlag auf
den Breitscheidplatz erinnern indem es
um den bisher schwersten islamistischen
Anschlag in der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland ging und hier im Parlament
ja da waren sie bei reißerischen reden
wenn es ums wenn es um das Thema
Islamismus gegen ja da waren sie immer
voll da aber das Arbeiten im
Untersuchungsausschuss haben sie nicht
gerade erfunden da sind sie in den
Sitzungen zwar immer dann aufgewacht
wenn sie ihre Hetze von Stapel lassen
konnten aber wenn es um die kleinteilige
und anstrengende Aufklärungsarbeit gegen
sind sie vollständig abgetaucht und Frau
von Storch
hat er irgendwann schon gar keine Lust
mehr zu kommen und Herr Seitz stellt
sich jetzt hier hin und gibt den Chef
Aufklärer aber hatte am Ende auch
irgendwie keine Lust mehr sich so
richtig an den Sitzungen zu beteiligen
dann haben sie jede Woche in anderen
Abgeordneten geschickt bis irgendwann
mal einer sitzen blieb am Ende waren sie
eben nicht bereit sich durch die
Aktenberge zu wühlen die Zusammenhänge
zu verstehen und wirkliche
Aufklärungsarbeit zu leisten und glaubt
ihr eigentlich irgendjemand glaubt ihr
irgendjemand dass es bei einem
Untersuchungsausschuss Corona irgendwie
anders wäre mit der AFD ich glaube das
nicht ihnen geht es
darum
eine neue Bühne für ihre Meinungsmache
und ihre Spaltung zu generieren denn
ansonsten sind sie einfach extrem faul
ja das muss man so sagen und ihre
Politik ist es auch
Mitglieder und Anhänger der AFD waren
schnell auf der Straße mit auf der
Straße gegen eine vermeintliche
maskendiktatur die AFD hat die
Gemengelage aus Impfgegnern Esoterikern
und rechtsextremen ganz gezielt genutzt
um zu mobilisieren sogar bis in die
öffentliche Anhörung des
Gesundheitsausschusses hinein in dieser
Woche was schäbig ist meine Damen und
Herren
und schon im August und schon im August
letzten Jahres haben wir alle erleben
müssen dass nicht nur in den USA Leute
aufgestachelt werden können
Parlamentsgebäude zu stürmen sondern
auch in Deutschland rechtsextreme und
gewaltbereite Personen Angriffe auf
demokratische Institutionen geplant und
auch versucht haben und die AFD war
immer vorne mit dabei die rechtsextreme
Ausrichtung ihrer Partei verstecken sie
ja schon gar nicht mehr sondern
profilieren sich als parlamentarische
Arm des Rechtsextremismus jede große
querdenken-demo bei den Personen auch
aus dem bürgerlichen Lager neben ihren
parteiangehörigen und anderen
rechtsextremen mitgelaufen sind haben
sie als Erfolg gefeiert und jetzt in
dieser schweren Zeit ist es ganz genauso
krisenprobleme
Ängste das sind die Koalitionspartner
der AFD wenn sie sonst schon keiner
haben und
sie hoffen auf eine weitere Verschärfung
der Gaskrise damit sie ihren heißen
Herbst bekommen genau das gleiche haben
sie in der corona-krise auch gemacht und
ich bin mir gar nicht vorstellen wie es
gewesen wäre wenn sie von der AFD in der
corona-krise Verantwortung getragen
hätten wenn es bei der
pandemiebekämpfung nach Ihren
Vorstellungen gegangen wäre während mehr
Menschen gestorben während die
Krankenhäuser und Pflegeheime noch
überlasteter gewesen hätten vulnerable
Gruppen deutlich weniger Schutz erfahren
ihre Forderungen sind unverantwortlich
meine Damen und Herren
und jetzt
und jetzt stellen Sie sich hier hin und
sagen sie wollen das Regierungshandeln
während der Pandemie aufarbeiten ich
kann das nur für einen schlechten Witz
halten meine Damen und Herren fangen sie
vielleicht mal bei sich selber an wenn
es um die Aufarbeitung geht liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
demokratischen Fraktionen lassen Sie
mich das zum Schluss noch sagen lassen
Sie uns bei allen inhaltlichen
Differenzen weiterhin klar
zusammenstehen gegen diesen
rechtsextremen Hass für den die AFD
steht auch und vor allem gerade in
diesen schwierigen Zeiten ganz
herzlichen Dank
Abgeordneter Brandner bevor sie den Saal
verlassen
ich Rüge ihren Zwischenruf bezogen auf
die Abgeordnete
welcher immerhin das Zeug einer
Beleidigung hat weil Wiederholung
behalte ich mir Ordnungsmaßnahmen vor
wir fahren in der Debatte fort das Wort
hat die Kollegen Kathrin Vogler für die
Fraktion
[Applaus]
geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Abgeordnete der
afd-fraktion wieder einmal versucht
diese Fraktion von Rechtsaußen aus der
Verunsicherung der Menschen in der
Pandemie politischen Profit zu schlagen
denn nichts anderes ist dieser Antrag
auf Einsetzung eines
Untersuchungsausschusses und es gibt
nichts zu beschönigen die
pandemie-politik der Bundesregierung war
oft fehlerhaft unzulänglich und
intransparent denken wir nur an die
aktuelle Vernichtung von 800 Millionen
abgelaufener ffp2-masken die hätte man
doch besser schon vor Wochen verschenken
können oder denken wir an Millionen
abgelaufener Impfstoffdosen und
Medikamente Deutschland hat gemeinsam
mit den anderen reichen Staaten den
Weltmarkt zu Höchstpreisen leer gekauft
so dass die Entwicklungsländer ihre
Bevölkerung nicht mehr Schützen konnten
das ist eine moralische Katastrophe
ersten Ranges aber das will die AFD
natürlich nicht untersuchen lassen und
schon deshalb ist dieser Antrag
abzulehnen
und auch hierzulande kamen viele
Entscheidungen leider zu spät oder war
nicht zielgenau und das hat unnötiges
Leid und unnötige Todesfälle verursacht
kovid 19 ist eben noch nicht vorbei auch
wenn Teile der Bundesregierung immer
wieder das suggerieren genau wie die AFD
letzte Woche sind über 600 Menschen an
und mit corvit 19 gestorben seit Januar
schon mehr als im gesamten Jahr 2020 und
deswegen müssen wir uns auch weiterhin
jederzeit die Frage stellen welche
Einschränkungen für alle Menschen
verhältnismäßig sind und welche Kosten
wir der Gesellschaft zumuten müssen um
Menschenleben und Gesundheit zu schützen
und an dieser ernsthaften Debatte sind
sie von der AFD überhaupt nicht
interessiert weil sie sich nämlich
entschlossen haben der parlamentarische
Arm von schwoblern und verharmlosern zu
sein wenn man sich einfach vorlügt das
corvit 19 gar keine tödliche Krankheit
ist dann erscheinen natürlich auch alle
staatlichen Maßnahmen als willkürliche
Eingriffe in die Freiheitsrechte der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger was sie nicht per
se sind und in ihrer Rolle als
parlamentarischer Arm der
verschwörungsszene sind sie allerdings
auch wieder unglaubwürdig erinnern Sie
sich noch erinnern sie sich noch dass
sie am 24 März 2020 auf der
drucksachennummer
1918106 hier ein Gesetzentwurf
eingebracht haben mit dem sie allen
Ernstes gefordert haben dass RKI sollte
weitreiche weitreichende Kompetenzen für
die Absage von Veranstaltungen oder
sogar für Schulschließungen bekommen und
die Bundesregierung sollte den Ländern
und Kommunen sogar Weisungen erteilen
können um nachlässiges Verhalten zu
bekämpfen meine Damen und Herren
erinnern Sie sich nicht vielleicht
sollten sie erstmal in ihrem eigenen
Laden einen Untersuchungsausschuss
aufmachen
und
Untersuchungsausschüsse sind ja das
schärfste Schwert des Parlaments
gegenüber der Regierung
angemessen einen ganzen Ausschuss mit 75
Fragen zu beschäftigen von denen die
allermeisten von fleißigen Abgeordneten
problemlos im Rahmen des
parlamentarischen frage-rechts geklärt
werden könnten diesen absurden
schaufensterantrag den wir ab
kündigt Katrin Vogler hier schon an
jetzt spricht für die FDP als nächstes
Stefan Tomé
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin für ihre
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Titel von
Jens spahns kürzlich vorgestellten Buch
wir werden einander viel verzeihen
müssen kommt nicht von ungefähr der
ehemalige
unionsgesetzminister geht darin grobe
Fehler in der corona-politik der letzten
Bundesregierung zu nun hat sich die FDP
weiß Gott immer gegen unverhältnismäßige
und massive Grundrechtseinschränkungen
in der corona-politik eingesetzt und die
Bürgerrechte verteidigt und jetzt in
Regierungsverantwortung hat die FDP
darauf hingewirkt dass ich in der
corona-politik ein Paradigmenwechsel
vollzogen hat weg von flächendeckenden
pauschalenfreies Einschränkungen hin zu
verhältnismäßigen und zielgenaueren
Maßnahmen meine Damen und Herren
und nun fordert die AFD eine
Aufarbeitung der corona-politik in einen
Untersuchungsausschuss das ist doch
nichts als der Versuch so lange wie
möglich parteipolitisch von der
coronakrise zu profitieren das Ziel ist
auch nicht eine konstruktiven Beitrag in
der parlamentarischen Debatte zu liefern
sondern sich in Applaus der
corona-leugner und der
Verschwörungstheoretiker solange wie
möglich zu sichern
ein Untersuchungsausschuss macht doch
nur dann wirklich Sinn wenn ein Vorgang
abgeschlossen ist und abschließend
beurteilt werden kann aber die aktuellen
coronazahlen ist läutet doch gar niemand
zeigen dass es für eine abschließende
Beurteilung noch zu früh ist ein
Untersuchungsausschuss dient auch dazu
Probleme zu identifizieren und raus
konkrete
Handlungsoptionen für die Regierung
abzuleiten die dann gegebenenfalls ein
Kurswechsel vollziehen kann das ist aber
jetzt unnötig geworden weil der
Regierungswechsel schon ein paradigmenwe
in der kronpolitik hervorgebracht hat
deswegen wäre das Ziel eine solchen
Untersuchungsausschuss eigentlich schon
jetzt überholt ich will nur ein paar
Beispiele nennen zum einen die
maskenaffäre dass sie die Ampelkoalition
drauf geeinigt dass es Verbot
unerlaubter Nebeneinkünfte in
Zusammenhang mit der Mandatsausübung
noch einmal neu geregelt werden muss
zweites Beispiel anstatt die
corona-politik an der Volksvertretung
vorbei zu machen wurden doch die
Debatten und die Entscheidung gezielt
hier hereingebracht in dieses Parlament
drittes Beispiel gerade die Impfpflicht
ist hier in diesem Parlament intensiv
ausgiebig debattiert und entschieden
worden und als viertes Beispiel hat
Corona sicherlich an vielen Stellen
Defizite der Digitalisierung in
Deutschland offengelegt und der
Digitalisierung Minister Volk
gewissingen hat hier schon eine
Aufholjagd angekündigt die jetzt auch im
Gange ist letztlich hat also der
Regierungswechsel zu mehr
Eigenverantwortung zu zielgenauernden
Maßnahmen und zu mehr Freiheit geführt
wir setzen die notwendigen
Schutzmaßnahmen um und auch einen
Impfschutz treiben wir jetzt in der
Diskussion voran ohne den Menschen
tiefgreifende freiheitseinschränkungen
zuzumuten
die FDP hat auch in den letzten Jahren
vieles in der corona-politik für falsch
gehalten aber ein Untersuchungsausschuss
ist nicht das ständige Mittel um
politische Entscheidungen zu untersuchen
die man selber für falsch hält in einem
Untersuchungsausschuss werden mit den
Instrumenten der Strafprozessordnung
politisches Skandale ausgeleuchtet nun
ist die corona-politik etwas anderes
nämlich
Tasten der Politik gewesen zwischen
solchen Bekämpfung einerseits und
grundrechtsgeldung andererseits das sind
auch nach unserer Auffassung vielfach
falsche Schwerpunktsetzungen erfolgt
aber nicht von derart dass er sie mit
den Mitteln der strafverordnung
aufklären müssten und deshalb werden wir
den Antrag der AFD auf Einsetzung eines
Untersuchungsausschusses ablehnen ich
danke Ihnen
Stefan thomey kündigt hier schon die
Ablehnung an allerdings wird dieser
Antrag ja erst einmal in die
entsprechenden Ausschüsse überwiesen
Nord diskutiert dann noch mal in Plenum
diskutiert und dann werden erst die
Abgeordneten darüber abstimmen Robert
fahle spricht jetzt seit Anfang
September fraktionslos ist aber
weiterhin noch Mitglied der Partei AFD
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren der
corona-untersuchungsausschuss ist
dringend notwendig berechtigt aber ein
wichtiges Thema ist in der Begründung
überhaupt noch nicht angesprochen das
will ich jetzt kurz ergänzen das ist
nämlich die Tatsache dass seit Beginn
der Impfkampagne in vielen Ländern mit
einer hohen Impfquote eine ungewöhnlich
hohe Übersterblichkeit zu verzeichnen
ist die mit den offiziellen
nachgewiesenen kovid 19 sterbefallzahlen
nicht erklärt werden kann
seit Beginn der Impfkampagnen herrschen
übersterblichkeitsraten von mehr als
zehn Prozent in Deutschland der EU USA
Großbritannien Schweiz und weiteren
Staaten es gibt Zeitungsmeldungen von
über 1.000 kollabierten gut trainierten
jungen Sportlern von denen 800 seit
Beginn der Impfkampagne gestorben sind
im pand 2020 gab es in Deutschland keine
Übersterblichkeit 21 hatten wir laut
einer Studie von Professor Dr Kubaner
und Professor Dr reitzner 25 bis 50.000
tote mehr als erwartet mittlerweile wird
das Thema auch von Mainstream Medien
aufgegriffen am 7 september von Welt
Online Überschrift Zitat rätselhafte
Todesfälle in Europa die Schweizer
Tageszeitung Blick einen Tag später
Epidemiologen Rätseln wegen
Übersterblichkeit
Korrelationsanalysen zeigen den klaren
Zusammenhang zwischen impfaktivität und
sterbedynamik covid 19 Impfstoffe lösen
Herzerkrankungen und Thrombosen aus das
ist hinlänglich bekannt und wurde von
Wissenschaftlern theoretisch begründet
und drittens durch Pathologen aus
Heidelberg durch Obduktionen im Detail
nachgewiesen warum wissen wir bis heute
nicht wer mit und wer an covid 19
verstorben ganz einfach weil Herr
Lauterbach als pharma-lobbyist nichts
für die Aufklärung dieser Todesfälle
unternommen hat ich fordere Herrn
Lauterbach auf schaffen Sie die
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht ab
stellen sie sich dem
Untersuchungsausschuss und treten sie
endlich zurück vielen Dank
[Applaus]
das Wort hat Dr Herbert Hollmann für die
SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren fährt natürlich
schwer nach diesem Unsinn den wir eben
gehört haben uns Manuskript hier sich zu
erhalten ich plane immer wieder was für
ein Unsinn hier ungestraft von sich
gegeben werden darf das ist unglaublich
welcher
medizinischer Unsinn hier ungestraft in
der Öffentlichkeit transportiert werden
darf das muss auch wirklich mal
hinterfragt werden wo sind denn die
Quellen für diesen ganzen Unsinn den Sie
hier zum Teil verbreiten
da bringen sie was von Sport und Toten
und was ich allen da hätten sie doch mal
zum gemeinsamen Ausschuss kommen können
Gesundheit und Sport verbesser Wohlfahrt
von der Charité ganz klar dargelegt hat
wie die Situation kovid und sportlich
verhält und Leistungssport aber es
wollen sie ja nicht hören
so meine lieben Damen und Herren komme
ich mal zurück auf das was wir heute zu
besprechen haben
dieser Ausschuss da der da jetzt hier
irgendwie beantragt werden soll oder
beantragt wird der entfällt 75
verschiedene Punkte vergleichen Sie das
mal mit dem Ausschussantrag Afghanistan
oder im Ausschuss das ist genau die
Hälfte davon daran sieht man ist eine
Aufzählung von nichts anderes als
pandemisch querdenkt den
Verschwörungstheorien ja sie sind die
Quelle dafür dass die Querdenker hier
diesen Zulauf bekommen haben und sie
sind verantwortlich dafür dass viele
Menschen wegen ihrer vermeintlichen
Gesundheitspolitik die falschen Schritte
gegangen sind
ich möchte mal folgendes sagen wenn man
ihren Antrag mal genauer sich ansieht
Punkt 10 geklärt werden soll ob die
Bundesregierung vor dem ausrufen des
lockdowns im März 2020 eine
folgeabschätzung in Hinsicht auf die
sozialen gesundheitlichen und
wirtschaftlichen Auswirkungen
vorgenommen haben dann machen sie das
Punkt 20 drei ich normal das ist auch
handwerklich miserabel entschuldigen sie
wie kann man denn am Anfang einer
Pandemie und ich muss Ihnen mal
folgendes sagen Deutschland und
Mitteleuropa kennt sowas ja gar nicht
mehr wir haben 60 70 Jahre ja gar nicht
mit Infektionskrankheiten zu tun gehabt
wie sollte man denn im Vorhinein
abschätzen können welche Folgen das hat
da war man doch von Minute zu Minute von
Tag zu Tag mit neuen Erkenntnissen
konfrontiert und musste darauf eingehen
was soll also diese Frage
siegfrieder sprechen sich ständig selbst
sie wollen oder Mängeln dass anfangs
angeblich nicht genug für
Schutzmasken bereitgestellt wurden und
andere Materialien Arztpraxen ich kenne
das Problem selber brauchen sie mir
nicht vor zu machen aber gerade sie ja
Teile ihrer Partei haben
anfangsmaskenpflicht gefordert und
Wochen oder Monate später fordern Sie
genau das Gegenteil das ist das Hin und
Her ihrer Politik sie stellen das
Fähnchen ins Wind ja das ist das das ist
doch das was typisch für sie ist sie
interessiert doch Gesundheitspolitik nur
wenn es wirklich in ihren Kram passt ja
sie wollen Desinformationen streuen und
das tun sie sie wollen Unruhe stiften
und mit der Angst der Menschen
Wählerstimmen gewinnen und das gelingt
ihnen leider auf vielen Gebieten dass
das einzige Potenzial was sie haben
leider ist es so
am Anfang am Anfang
der Pandemie konnte es Ihnen gar nicht
genug schnell schnell genug gehen und
welche Maßnahmen zu erreichen am 4 März
2020 stand vor allem ließ Weigel hier
wohl an dem Pult und forderte die von
der Bundesregierung schärfere Maßnahmen
zu ergreifen und zielte dann zitierte
dann Professor Thorsten auch Herr
gauland stand hier am Plenum und hat
sogar am 25 März die Regierung hier
gelobt
ja ja
wenige Monate später wollen sie von all
dem nichts mehr wissen
dasselbe Problem haben wir oder dasselbe
Vorgehen oder die Taktik von ihnen haben
wir bei den Impfstoffen erst wurde die
Bundesregierung dafür beschimpft oder
kritisiert die impfstoffbeschaffung sei
zu schleppend und nicht ausreichend dann
Zetteln sie bald danach eine Kampagne an
wo die Impfstoffe verteufelt werden das
ist doch ein Widerspruch nach dem
anderen niemand wird abstreiten dass man
rückblickend manches hätte anders machen
können aber wie sagen wir als Mediziner
zu den Pathologen das sind die
postmortalen Klugscheißer also auf
deutsch gesagt
auf deutsch gesagt hinterher bin ich
immer schlauer
er steht ihnen ja freie sich konstruktiv
zu beteiligen und statt immer wieder
ungeprüft Studien aus obskuren Quellen
hier vorzubringen
wahrscheinlich liegt es auch daran dass
es ihrer Fraktion wirklich an
medizinischen Sachverstand mangelt muss
man ganz ehrlich sagen ihre einzige
glaube ich medizinische etwas
vorgebildete Zahnärztin ist heute auch
nicht da ist auch besser so muss ich
sagen aber
dieser es ist ja okay wie gehen Sie dann
mit uns um oder mit anderen Gruppen das
muss man auch mal hier durch die sagen
ich mache es kurz ich habe nur noch zwei
Sekunden ob in der Gesundheitspolitik
oder wo auch immer sie haben nur ein
Ziel die Demokratie zu unterwandern da
machen wir nicht mit heute nicht und
auch nicht in Zukunft
Arbeit wollen man hat hier sich an die
AFD gewandt etwas
grundsätzlicher ist er da geworden mit
seiner Kritik an der Fraktion und damit
können wir hier zum letzten Redner in
dieser Debatte das ist Patrick Schnieder
für die Unionsfraktion
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen liebe
Kollegen meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren
angesichts dieser Debatte und wenn man
den Antrag sehr intensiv gelesen hat
muss man sich zunächst mal fragen kann
man das alles überhaupt ernst nehmen was
da geschrieben ist ich will ihnen
darlegen dass und warum man das ernst
nehmen sollte denn es führt zu
interessanten Schlussfolgerungen
nun hat sich der Kollege Brandner ja
schon vom Acker gemacht der hat
zwischendurch mal gerufen ist der beste
Antrag der hier je vorgelegt worden ist
wenn man das mal juristisch betrachtet
und der Kollege Brandner nennt sich ja
juristisch betrachtet muss man sagen der
hätte in keinem Seminar in keiner
Vorlesung erstes Semester
Staatsorganisationsrecht auch nur
Bestand würde man sagen setzen sechs
wiederholen noch mal versuchen warum
weil er grundlegende
verfassungsrechtliche Fragen vollkommen
ignoriert erstens bundesstaatsprinzip
wir haben eine föderale Ordnung in
Deutschland die meisten Maßnahmen sind
auf Länderebene getroffen worden hier
ist zu einem
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz koordiniert
worden von der Bundeskanzlerin ein
Bundeskanzler an die Maßnahmen die
Länderparlamente die Länder getroffen
und so weit reicht eben die Kompetenz
des Bundes und damit auch des
Bundestages bei der Einsetzung eines
Untersuchungsausschusses nicht
das zu überprüfen zweiter Fall ein
grundlegendes Prinzip des deutschen
Verfassungen Verwaltungsrecht das
Bestimmtheitsgebot sie legen hier einen
Zeitraum vor stellen aber Fragen die sie
aus dem Zeitraum gar nicht beantworten
lassen sondern weit über diesen Zeitraum
hinaus reicht vollkommen widersprüchlich
drittens es gibt einen
Grundsatz bei der Frage der Einsetzung
von parlamentarischen
Untersuchungsausschüssen der heißt wir
können nachträglich nur abgeschlossene
Sachverhalte begutachten was machen Sie
sie begutachten ein Sachverhalt der
heute noch abgeschlossen ist sie geben
das sogar zu in ihren Fragen also auch
das widersprüchlich und gegen das
geltende Recht verstoßen und nur ein
letztes Beispiel von vielen die
fortsetzen könnte ein Klassiker übrigens
ja nicht der erste Antrag auf Einsetzung
eines Untersuchungsausschusses den sie
stellen sie nehmen das Ergebnis der
Fragestellungen schon vorweg sie nehmen
Werten vorweg was sie eigentlich erst
aufklären wollen auch das ist
vollkommener Nonsens macht das
verfassungsrechtlich hinfällig
aber ich will das auch politisch noch
bewerten hier ist ja auch gesagt worden
und schon dargelegt worden wie schlampig
hier gearbeitet worden ist nicht nur
juristisch schlampig gearbeitet worden
ist das sind Fragen dabei die einfach
wiederholend reinkopiert worden sind
wortwörtlich gleich es sind Fragen dabei
die inhaltlich schon mal gestellt worden
sind auch das bläht das Ding auf und es
zeigt dass Interesse besteht gar nicht
darin diese Fragen beantwortet zu
bekommen und das sind wir beim Kern der
Dinge und bei den Schlussfolgerungen die
wir zu ziehen haben
sie setzen ja auf auf
Verschwörungstheorien Sie interessiert
gar nicht was hier wissenschaftlich an
Erkenntnissen zu ziehen ist was für
folgende Pandemien für unser Verhalten
hierauszuziehen ist sie setzen auf
Verschwörungstheorien auf und was ich
besonders beschämend finde sie erwähnen
in ihrem Antrag nicht mit einem Wort die
vielen tausenden Toten die die krank
geworden sind die heute noch leiden
unter Spätfolgen das ist nicht nur
empathielos
das ist nicht nur empathielos sondern
damit dass sie die nicht mal erwähnen
sondern hier am Rednerpult herrsalz zum
Teil auch noch in die Richtung
gesprochen haben sie instrumentalisieren
diese Menschen für ihre schäbigen
politischen Zwecke das kann man nur
verurteilen
deshalb meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren die Schlussfolgerungen sind klar
der Antrag ist inhaltlich vollkommen
schlampig und schlecht gemacht der ist
juristisch unterirdisch es politisch
durchschaubar und er ist menschlich
wirklich vollkommen daneben und ich kann
nur sagen so miserabel wie der Antrag
ist so eine solch miserable Alternative
wären sie und sind sie für dieses Land
[Applaus]